l'onu examine en ce moment la plainte de
la libye sous les américains baisse le
son la tension est retombée en
méditerranée nouvel accroc entre le
gouvernement et le parti socialiste la
sphère de la mairie de marseille sème le
trouble à gauche
gros contrat pour peugeot
un accord qui lie avec l'iran pour
fabriquer les 4 enfin 10 milliards de
francs sur 10 ans britt lalande veux une
france propre le feu de la terre d'état
à l'environnement part en guerre contre
les décharges sauvages les déchets
toxiques
indiana jones numéro 3 ce sera en
septembre premières images du film en
exclusivité à la fin de ce journal
bonsoir et avant de développer tous ses
titres cette information qui intéresse
tout le monde il s'agit de l'ulcère à
l'estomac 3 à 4 millions de français ont
fait ou vont faire à un moment de leur
vie un ulcère il faut le savoir
jusqu'à présent on ne savait pas trop ce
qui provoquait c'est ulcère on parlait
du stress bien sûr et bien des médecins
français viennent de faire une enquête
très vaste elle contredit bien des idées
reçues notamment sur le stress alain
labouze l'ulcère un trou dans l'estomac
ou le dieu des normes qui fait mal et
qui peut vous plier en deux vues en
endoscopie ici c'est un cratère qui se
creuse dont on ne sait pratiquement rien
aujourd'hui pour la première fois en
france une grande étude sur 1800
personnes souffrant d'ulcères permettent
enfin de savoir qui risquent vraiment un
ulcère les gens stressés les français à
bout de nerfs non c'est faux
l'étude conclut que le risque d'une
serre liées au stress est très faible
de même que l'ulcère du cadres surmenés
survolté et en prise avec des
responsabilités terrible et bien ce type
d'ulcères n'existe pas non plus de
risque
curieusement on s'est aperçu que les
sujets en ile-de-france avait plus
d'ulcères du duodénum s'aperçut
également que les agriculteurs avaient
plus d'une serre ges pris et on s'est
aperçu que les sujets qui avaient perdu
leur conjoint avait également plus dû le
faire pourquoi les agriculteurs en
première ligne face à l'ulcère mystère
mais on constate qu'ils sont 50% de plus
parmi les ulcères gastriques
l'autre grosse population touchée par
l'ulcère les maghrébins ils sont six
fois plus ulcéreux que les autres et une
alimentation trop épicé n'y serait pour
rien même chose pour le café et
peut-être même l'alcool qui ne serait
pas responsable de l'ulcère revanche
trop d'aspirine et surtout le tabac sont
à coup sûr des facteurs de risque
reste que la cause de la maladie
ulcéreuse est toujours inconnue
heureusement les médecins parviennent
quand même à soulager leurs malades
grâce à des médicaments qui aujourd'hui
ont cicatrisé les ulcères dans 80 à 90%
des cas les suite de l'accrochage aérien
entre américains et libya je vous
rappelle que deux avions libyens ont été
abattus hier par la flotte américaine
provoquant de nombreuses réactions dans
le monde
aujourd'hui la tension est un petit peu
retombé en ce moment même à l'onu la
plainte de la libye est examiné par le
conseil de sécurité à washington les
autorités américaines ont déclaré
qu'elles avaient des preuves de
l'attitude hostile des deux avions
libyens
jacquat bouchard à washington invité
d'honneur d'une manifestation mondaine
organisée contre la drogue à los angeles
en ald rega n'a rien dit sur l'incident
aérien de libye le président serait
maintenant opposé à une attaque contre
l' usine chimique libyennes en raison de
la forte opposition manifestée par les
alliés des etats unis
l'essentiel pour nous est que kadhafi se
sentent nerveux et mal à l'aise a
déclaré george schultz avant son départ
pour paris
les officiels autant que la presse
américaine se garde bien de crier
victoire
sans doute la libye at elle reçu un
nouvel avertissement
mais selon les journaux le scénario
envisagé à washington n'était pas celui
là
et les leaders du congrès qui ont
approuvé l'action militaire d'hier ne
veulent pas entendre parler d'une
escalade au moins dans l'immédiat
le dossier est maintenant entre les
mains de monsieur perez de cuellar et du
conseil de sécurité qui doit étudier la
plainte libyenne contre les états unis
s'il remonte provisoirement l'épée au
foro les américains demeurent vigilants
sur la sphère de lusine libyenne
d'ailleurs georges chose entend bien
enfoncer le clou à la conférence de
paris sur les armes chimiques pour
souligner le caractère à ses yeux
dangereux et même effrayant du projet
libyen
la politique française qu'elle pastis
marseille la sphère de la mairie et
l'exclusion hier de robert vigouroux du
parti socialiste provoque des remous et
pas seulement à marseille puisque l'
affaire a provoqué même un clash
aujourd'hui entre pierre joxe et pierre
mauroy
nous allons y revenir mais depuis je
vous propose de voir ce qu'on disait
aujourd'hui sur le port de marseille de
l'exclusion du ps du mr robert vigouroux
patrice volet luc bachofen report
incertain vous savez avant ça se voyait
pas ça avant
et c'est pour cette même thème dire que
la place est bonne alors il ya beaucoup
de candidatures je passe ma vie est un
panier un prix décent donc en même temps
avoir jusque là rien ou presque n'a
changé sur la canebière car après
l'exclusion la bataille continue
sur le front du conseil municipal plus
de majorité stable
robert vigouroux seul contre presque
tous s'accrochent aux dossiers en cours
lundi il a perdu une partie de ses plus
fidèles soutiens dilemme cornélien pour
quelques socialistes soutenir vigouroux
et risquer l'exclusion ou s'aligne sur
peser subir sa loi
certains pensent à une troisième voie la
neutralité active je participerai au
combat des socialistes contre l'arrivée
de la droite et d'extrême droite place
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas condamnés
à être sur les niches sociales sur tous
les cas est ce que vous diriez que le ps
marseillais et convalescents ou est-ce
qu'il est encore malade
écoutez ça va pas bien si je peux pas
mentir ça va pas bien et je
je suis convaincu qu'on peut gagner
cette ville en étant tous au coude à
coude et je ne me résoudrai pas à faire
de mon ami d'hier mon ennemi de demain
paradoxal donc cette clarification venu
de paris dans la course à la mairie
certains hommes de poids dans la gauche
socialiste pourrait se préserver
s'éviter un choix trop compromettants
pour leur avenir politique
parra force du bureau exécutif robert
vigouroux est aujourd'hui hors de cette
querelle socialo-socialiste face à
lui-même pour un autre défi mené
campagne sans parti avec le seul soutien
des dix sept mille signatures
recueillies par les comités vigouroux et
ce matin donc pierre joxe a pris le
parti de robert vigouroux disant qu'il
était son ami pierre mauroy lui a
aussitôt répliqué en disant que ce type
de décision relever de la rue de
solferino du ps et non pas du ministère
de l'intérieur gilles leclerc c'est une
affaire qui prend une ampleur inattendue
oui exclusion le voit ce soir ne
signifie pas bien au contraire fin des
divisions mais plutôt on peut le dire
crispation l' affaire marseillaise avait
déjà depuis longtemps franchi les
limites du vieux-port remonté le rhône
pour venir
dione à proximité des berges de la seine
et aujourd'hui il ya bien eu coup de
vent entre le gouvernement et le parti
socialiste au sujet de ce dossier en
effet déjà depuis de longues semaines la
méthode du parti socialiste a été
critiquée jusqu'au plus haut c'est à
dire à l'elysée françois mitterrand
avait souhaité plutôt une entente une
ébauche de compromis
visiblement pierre mauroy et michel
pezet romieux préféré en bout de course
une clarification beaucoup plus brutale
alors cela dit gilles c'est pas le
premier incident qui est entre le
gouvernement et le vfb il y en a eu
d'autres
chacun se souvient par exemple toujours
à propos de marseille de l'affrontement
en récents au mois de novembre entre
pierre joxe et les socialistes à
l'assemblée en novembre dernier à propos
du découpage de marseille mais si on
remonte encore un petit peu plus dans le
temps le premier signe d'une fêlure
entre l'elysée et le parti socialiste
était intervenue au moment de la
désignation du patron des socialistes
françois mitterrand souvenez-vous avait
préféré à ce moment là laurent fabius
c'est pierre mauroy qui l'avait emporté
bon cela dit c'est une affaire grave ou
pas la seule fois ne dramatisons pas pas
de dramatisation a même dit tout à
l'heure
françois mitterrand l'elysée pour qui
recevait les journalistes au moment des
voeux marseille at il dit c'est la
sphère des partis politiques et non pas
la faire
non toujours est il ce soir que le
navire socialiste à marseille est très
fragile et que de nouvelles tempêtes
auraient du mal à lui faire remonter le
cours
merci gilles en tout cas la préparation
des municipales agite tous les partis à
gauche par exemple le pc et le ps était
réuni aujourd'hui un accord entre les
deux parties en vue des prochaines
municipales se présente sous une bonne
perspective a indiqué marcel debarge
pour secrétaire national du ps en tout
cas une dernière réunion préparatoire
entre les deux délégations aura lieu
mardi prochain
voilà à droite udf et rpr on régler ce
matin plus de la moitié des cas
litigieux et deux grands partis se
revoyaient ce soir alors voyons tout de
suite à droite si la situation s'est un
peu décantées véronique sainte olive je
t'aime moi non plus toute la journée rpr
et udf se sont jouées le grand air de la
séduction premier couplet ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale la commission
juppé gaudin ouvre le dossier des
municipales 17 cas de ville difficile et
lyon qui se présente comme le cas le
plus épineux
mais l'atmosphère est à l'optimisme
deux heures plus tard alain juppé
traverse la rue et au siège du rpr
ils dénoncent la position centriste en
particulier l'article de bernard bosson
au monde
cette déclaration sera t il justifier et
annoncé dans un des gens l'existence
d'une liste centriste aux élections
européennes lors qu'on s'entend de bien
nous sommes militaires mais nous sommes
pas contrariant
en début d'après-midi le ballet
recommence au siège de l'udf cette fois
giscard n'a qu'un souci réunir la
famille autour d'une plateforme sur
l'europe
les centristes réclament quelques
amendements au texte proposé l'union au
sein de l'udf est à ce prix jusqu'à est
prête à le payer
l'union avec le rpr c'est pour plus tard
depuis le début je suis partisan d'une
démarche cohérente sur l'affairé opel et
cette démarche cohérente cela consiste à
définir les objectifs européens de la
france pour la période à venir
nous avons défini ce que l'udf proposent
leur père de son côté a élaboré les
siens nous allons regarder si ces
objectifs sont compatibles c'est le sac
prochain de notre conversation je
souhaite qu'ils le soient le troisième à
2 se joue en ce moment même à
l'assemblée les partenaires de
l'opposition se sont donné jusqu'à
minuit pour publier les bans des listes
électorales la france ne doit pas
devenir la poubelle de l'europe c'est le
secrétaire d'état à l'environnement
brice lalonde qui dit cela
brice lalonde a entrepris une offensive
contre les décharges sauvages d'ordures
ménagères et aussi contre les décharges
de produits toxiques
mais il ya du travail à faire l'année
dernière pour le magazine édition
spéciale une équipe d'antenne 2 s'était
rendu dans une décharge à ciel ouvert
dans l'oise précisément à néry saint tin
il y avait alors beaucoup de produits
toxiques dans cette décharge à ce moment
là c'était en octobre 87 le préfet
s'était engagé à faire nettoyer la
décharge alors voyez ce qu'il est advenu
avec ce nouveau reportage de dominique
verdeilhan et christian l'euro octobre
87 15 ans après la fermeture d'une
prétendue entreprise de retraitement des
déchets industriels des milliers de fûts
de déchets toxiques sont encore stockés
sans aucune surveillance dans cette
clairière près de néri dans l'oise de 65
à 72 la plupart des industries chimiques
ont fait transporter ici leurs ordures
industriels à l'air libre
on découvre ainsi des extincteurs au
bromure de méthyle éventrés des solvants
des chlorures les acides nocifs du
cyanure de potassium du poison à la
portée de n'importe quel promeneur
durant quinze ans la société rhodan est
responsable de cette exploitation a fait
la sourde oreille aux exigences d
sipa lité limitrophes qui lui demandait
d'évacuer ces fûts faire des
établissements spécialisés
devant ce mutisme renfoncer longtemps
par l'absence de lois régissant la
surveillance des transports et dépôt de
déchets toxiques
le préfet de l'oise s'engage à l'automne
87 à prendre le dossier en main on passe
dans une phase suivante
sur le plan réglementaire c'est à dire
qui permet aux pouvoirs publics de se
substituer à l'entrepreneur défaillant
en faisant faire faire aux frais de
celui ci les travaux qui lui paraissent
nécessaires janvier 89
il ne reste presque plus rien sur le
site tous les bâtiments en tôle ondulée
véritable laboratoire improvisés ont été
débarrassés de leurs flacons ses fûts
rouge ce sont des fûts de
reconditionnement
ils servent à évacuer les 400 tonnes de
cette poudre blanchâtre un dérivé de
pesticides
cette poule les stocker dans des sacs
plastique puis dans des fûts scellé en
tout ce seront deux mille cinq cents fut
qui vont être expédiés en allemagne où
ils seront enterrés dans une mine de sel
à 700 mètres de profondeur
l'identification puis reconditionnement
sur les deux tâches les plus durs pour
lan raid l'agencé nationale chargée de
la récupération et de l'élimination des
déchets coût des travaux plus de 1
million de francs à la charge pour
l'instant ne l'est pas gratter la couche
superficielle qui est pollué cette
couche superficielle va être mis en
décharge également et à partir de là on
va remblayage de la terre neuve au
dessus pour redonner un aspect ciré
correct au site mais reste les dizaines
de milliers de litres de produits
toxiques qui ont été déversées
directement dans le sol reste des
milliers de bidons qui ont été enfouis à
la va-vite à plusieurs mètres de
profondeur
une quantité incalculable de déchets
toxiques qui ont fait de cette clairière
une poubelle chine obligé de continuer à
vivre avec ce que nous avons ici sous
nos pieds qui est polluée pour x années
où xx e siècle on n'en sait rien avec
des choses que nous connaissons que tout
à fait partiellement une peupleraie
anéanti des cours d'eau pollués 12
hectares presque rajeunie en surface qui
ne doivent pas faire oublier cannary le
mal est en profondeur voilà je reviens à
l'instant sur la préparation des
municipales nous en parlions tout à
l'heure pendant que le sujet était
diffusée j'apprenais et véronique sainte
au livre m'a fait savoir qu'un accord
vient justement d'être signé entre l'udf
et le rpr s'est fait donc il y aura des
listes communes dans 220 grandes villes
sur 240 voilà donc l'accord qui vient
d'être signé entre l'udf et le rpr
peugeot renoue avec l'iran un accord
vient d'être conclu entre la firme
française est la plus grosse société
automobile iranienne sur 10 ans 500 1405
serait construite c'est un bon contrat
pour peugeot qui d'ailleurs est en bonne
santé puisque en 88 on la suit
aujourd'hui son chiffre d'affaires a
progressé de 22% nicolas jacobs
dans la banlieue de téhéran usines
automobiles hirane caudrot en bout de
chaîne ce seront bientôt des 405 peugeot
qui défileront sous le portrait de
l'ayatollah montazeri
le dauphin de kobenni 500000 exemplaires
en tout seront fabriqués ici dans les
dix prochaines années
dans un premier temps avec en majeure
partie des pièces d'origine française
puis progressivement seront intégrés des
pièces iranienne actuellement le fleuron
de l'iram caudrot c'est la paix cannes
depuis 1966 plus d'un million
d'exemplaires ont été produits peugeot
va fournir les moteurs et les trains
roulants de cette voiture en tout
soixante mille ensembles mécaniques
ajouté à la fabrication des 405 le
contrat représente 8 à 10 milliards de
francs
une affaire en or pour peugeot je pense
que sauf élément politique ou politico
militaire grave
tout milite en faveur d'un re
développement et d'un redéploiement
d'iran au plan industriel auquel nous
souhaitons participer et pas de
soubresauts dans l'histoire de du régime
iranien
je ne suis pas qualifié pour répondre à
cette question qui est une question
politique mais si l'on envisage tous les
tous les avatars politiques qui peuvent
se produire avec tous les partenaires
possibles en dehors du rentrent alors on
ne fera jamais rien
le jour nous en fait des relations
commerciales que la guerre iran irak
avait interrompu et c'est d'ailleurs le
premier contre un important qu'un
industriel français conclut avec les
iraniens depuis la fin du conflit
oui d'ailleurs les iraniens semblent
décidés à augmenter leur coopération
avec la france dans le domaine
économique mais ce n'est pas sans
arrière-pensée écouter ce que disait à
notre envoyé spécial patricia cost le
vice-premier ministre iranien les
relations entre la france et l'iran sont
en train de s'améliorer et de se
développer différentes délégations
françaises techniques et économiques
dans le domaine agricole hydraulique
c'est relié industriels sont aussi venus
à terre des négociations sont en cours
un climat de dialogue et nous pensons
que la france a beaucoup de possibilités
et que nous aboutirons à des accords qui
correspondront aux intérêts des deux
pays mais ce qui est certain c'est que
ces relations dont relèvent les volontés
politiques et pas seulement économiques
nouvelles journées de voeux à l'elysée
pour le président mitterrand le
président a reçu les représentants des
assemblées
il a reçu aussi les forces vives du pays
c'est-à-dire patronat syndicats
associations et puis aussi la presse cet
après midi au cours de ses voeux cette
information qui est un nouveau geste de
la france vis-à-vis des palestiniens
monsieur mitterrand a annoncé que le
bureau de l'ol paie à paris allait être
élevé au rang de délégation générale de
palestine
explication bernard benyamin c'était il
ya tout juste deux mois à alger le
conseil national palestinien se terminer
yasser arafat faisaient adopté par les
membres du conseil
la reconnaissance de la résolution 242
des nations unies autrement dit l'ol
perd reconnaissez implicitement
l'existence de l'état d'israël
une décision saluée par l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale
et d'abord par la france qui dès le
lendemain de cette déclaration laissé
entendre le statut de l'ol fait d'un
autre pays pourrait être élevé dans un
avenir proche
la suite c'est à dire stockholm et
genève n'ont fait que confirmer la
volonté de paix affichée par yasser
arafat
il ne restait donc plus à françois
mitterrand qu'a confirmé ce soir une
promesse faite au début du mois de
novembre
l'ol paie n'avait jusqu'à présent qu'un
bureau à paris dirigée par ibrahim
sousse
elle devient délégation générale de
palestine en fait un bureau très élargie
mais sans bénéficier pour autant d'un
statut diplomatique
voyons maintenant d'autres faits
marquants de l'actualité de ce jeudi en
bresse en images avec jean bart qui nous
plusieurs pains d'explosif à base de
centex découverts mercredi sur la
frontière entre les deux irlande dans
des caches d'armes de l'armée
républicaine irlandaise
lire très difficile à détecter dans les
aéroports le semtex un explosif puissant
fabriqué en tchécoslovaquie pourrait
être celui utilisé dans l'attentât
contre le vol 103 de la panam le 21
décembre dernier 270 morts à ce jour la
police britannique a toujours affirmé
que la libye était le fournisseur
privilégié des extrémistes de l'ira
en dépit des apparences fidel castro est
resté calme hier soir le lider maximo a
confirmé publiquement que le 10 janvier
prochain 3000 soldats cubains quitteront
l'angola aux termes de l'accord signé en
décembre dernier aux nations unies par
cuba l'angola et l'afrique du sud en
échange du retrait progressif de 50
mille soldats du corps expéditionnaire
cubain l'afrique du sud s'est engagée à
ne plus soutenir militairement les
adversaires du gouvernement angolais
frau communiste l'accord ne met pas un
terme à la guerre civile en angola mais
il ouvre la voie à l'indépendance de la
namibie ex colonie allemande aux mains
de l'afrique du sud depuis 1920
et
discussions tous azimuts au pakistan pro
américain pour le diplomate soviétique
you lie vorontsov responsable numéro un
du dossier afghan
il laisse parfois entendre que les
soviétiques pourrait partir plus
lentement que prévu si les accords de
genève ne sont pas respectés par le
pakistan et les mouvements de résistance
mais sur le terrain le retrait se
poursuit en particulier celui des
fonctionnaires soviétique confirmée par
l'envoyé spécial du new york times à
kaboul
cinquante mille soldats soviétiques
doivent encore quitter l'afghanistan
avant le 15 février prochain le forum de
l'expansion c'est pierre bérégovoy le
ministre des finances qui en était
l'invité tout à l'heure au cours de ce
forum les différents intervenants se
sont montrés plutôt optimistes pour
l'économie française en 89
réponse de pierre bérégovoy qui a
confirmé que le gouvernement d'ailleurs
poursuivi sa politique de rigueur
réponse du ministre donc espérons que
les optimistes ne se trompe pas philippe
sassier j'espère que les optimistes se
trompe-t-on moins cette année que les
pessimistes il ya un an devant les
dirigeants d'entreprise réunis au forum
de l'expansion qui a amerri govou a
voulu se montrer plus prudents que
certains devins de la conjoncture
économique est râpé que l'an passé à
même époque il annonçait la tempête
alors que nous bénéficions d'un beau
temps inconnu depuis 15 ans en matière
de salaires oui at il dit aux
négociations mais pas tous et pas tout
de suite
il faut at il dit renforcer le dialogue
social mais ne pas lui sacrifier la
rigueur nécessaire investir à savant
consommer nous devons tout faire pour
encourager l'investissement privé et
public et nous devons naturellement
continuer à maîtriser la consommation
privée
la demande privée et publique
d'où la nécessité de continuer à mener
une politique monétaire
et budgétaire rigoureuse et c'est bien
cette politique que j'ai reçu mandat
hier en conseil des ministres de
continuer tout au long de 1989
cette politique monétaire sérieuse
suppose que l'on évite tout et râpage
dérapages qui pourraient être liées à
l'inflation à l'excès de dépenses
publiques ou à l'excès de crédit
et puis il y eut des questions sur le
franc sur l'épargné sur l'europe de
réponse importante qu'il n'y aura pas de
dévaluation du froid des piats bérégovoy
plus si les allemands rêvent à lui nous
ferions la même chose enfin qu'en ce qui
concerne la libre circulation des
capitaux en europe elle ne sera pas
remise en cause
une baisse riom notre fiscalité sur les
pales s'il le fallait a précisé le
ministre nouveau rebondissement dans le
feuilleton michel droit clos grellier le
juge a renvoyé michel droit devant le
tribunal correctionnel
l'académicien était réinculquer de
corruption passive
il aurait continué de toucher de
l'argent du groupe hersant après sa
nomination à la cncl
ce rebondissement n'est pas un hasard
aujourd'hui en effet le juge grellier
quitter aujourd'hui ses fonctions pour
devenir vice présidente du tribunal de
grande instance de paris
pascal deschamps le juge grenier aura
donc mis à profit ces dernières heures
de magistrats instructeurs pour apporter
la touche finale un épineux dossier
qu'il instruisait depuis de longs mois
en mai 88 il inculpe michel droit de
corruption passive
deux mois plus tard c'est au tour du
directeur général de la société éditrice
du figaro d'être inculpé de corruption
active
le dossier des versements réguliers du
groupe hersant touché par l'académicien
alors qu'il était membre de la cncl
les deux inculpés proteste il ne s'agit
pas d'un salaire mais d'une indemnité de
départ et de droits d'auteur du figaro
histoire pour preuve cinq lettres
échangées par les deux hommes dès la fin
86 pour mettre au point les versements
pourtant pour les enquêteurs de la
police judiciaire ces lettres seraient
des faux fabriqué dans la précipitation
accusation formellement rejeté par les
intéressés l'avocat de michel droit ne
comprends pas ce soir
la décision du juge grelier savez quand
tu as un dossier se termine on sait ce
qu'il ya dedans tout était réglé tout
est expliqué
il n'y avait pas l'ombre d'un soupçon
d'une corruption d'un corrompu et
lacombe nous attendions le non lieu avec
plein certitude alors je ne suis pas
seulement super fait je suis attristé
c'est un bon coup médiatique
c'est un mauvais coup pour la justice
coup médiatique le juge grenier pourrait
bien être allé un peu vite en besogne
il a pris sa décision sans attendre les
réquisitions du parquet
contrairement à ce que prévoit le code
de procédure pénale le renvoi des
inculpés pourraient donc être annulée
dans la chambre d'accusation qui
désignerait un nouveau juge car depuis
aujourd'hui une seule chose est sûre le
juge grelier ne s'occupera plus jamais
de la sphère droit et ce jeudi la cncl
publier son bilan précisément son
rapport annuel un gros rapport de 500
pages pour expliquer son action un bilan
12 amer pour ce rapport qui sera en
effet le dernier puisque la cncl est
appelé à être remplacé prochainement par
le csa le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
nouvelle révélation sur la sphère
valente cette fois c'est pierre joxe le
ministre de l'intérieur qui sur europe 1
a dénoncé le comportement dangereux et
les méthodes de charles pasqua son
prédécesseur dans cette affaire
l'intervention de jean-charles marchiani
aurait gêné les négociations selon
monsieur joxe cela confirme les
informations que nous vous donnions dans
ce journal il ya deux jours pierre joxe
précise d'ailleurs qu'il n'y a jamais eu
de collaboration entre charles pasqua
lui sur cette affaire même si au moment
de la libération des deux fillettes
ils se trouvaient tous les deux dans le
même hôtel au maroc 1789 1989 200 ans
que les privilèges ont été abolis ont
ils étaient vraiment aboli ces
privilèges que donne la fortune la
naissance ou l'éducation
bonne question réponse ce soir dans le
magazine édition spéciale présentée par
claude sérillon à 22h15 une enquête très
complète vous verrez en voici quelques
exemples
là écoutez je ne la connais pas mais je
ne pense pas tout ce soir mes chevaux
jamais actuellement 6 et jeu mais je
crois qu'ils sont sortis dans le lot qui
précédait enfin ils sont en tout point
semblable
qu'est ce que c'est un privilège d'avoir
un circuit chez soi ah ouais quand même
si ça c'est pas un vrai village qu'est
ce que c'est vous voyagez dans un avion
personnel est ce que vous sentez
privilégiées oui je me sens toujours
prévu des chiffres par rapport aux gens
qui juste autour de nous c'est
incontestable
et quand on arrive avec une grosse
voiture comme la vôtre on est bien
accueillis ou mal accueillie très bien
accueilli c'est un passeport
extraordinaire vous arriver qu'une rose
tout de suite les vendeuses se précipite
sur vous et contrairement à ce qu'on
croit là on vous fait le prix parce
qu'on veut vous garder comme souvenirs
qu'est-ce qu'ils acceptent de céder à
rien je trouve que tout ça va très bien
tout cas pour moi voilà bien sûr si vous
êtes téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 des
privilèges nous vous en offrons chaque
jour vous le savez ce soir par exemple
dans le journal le privilège de voir en
exclusivité les premières images d'
indiana jones numéro trois c'est le
nouveau film de steven spielberg j'y
arriverai c'est l'une des plus grosses
superproductions de 89 en salles à
l'automne seulement alors regardez bien
après les aventuriers de l'arche perdue
et le temple maudit voici la dernière
croisade
le troisième épisode d' indiana jones
les prises de vue et les effets spéciaux
viennent tout juste de s'achever
après six mois de tournage entre
l'angleterre l'espagne et la californie
pour la troisième fois on voit se
reformer le trio vedette harrison ford
steven spielberg et george lucas ce
producteur et inventeur du personnage d'
indiana jones mais un nouveau venu fait
son entrée dans la famille c'est sean
connery une joue le père de
l'archéologue le docteur enjoy
le secret le plus total reste gardé sur
le scénario jusqu'à la sortie du film
prévue pour la france à l'automne
prochain
voilà il y avait un tiercé quarté +
c'était aujourd'hui à vincennes alors
voici les résultats
11 15 8 je vous laisse lire les rapports
pour le quarté + 11 15 8 et 16 des
chiffres que pirette vous avez donné
c'est toujours bon à signaler pirate bay
reste bien sûr les résultats du kart et
vous les avez
voilà les pieds avant de terminer ce
journal des nouvelles de christine
ockrent beaucoup de téléspectateurs nous
ont demandé des nouvelles de la santé de
ma consoeur christine alors je voudrais
vous dire qu'elle va mieux
elle devrait même pouvoir quitter
l'hôpital la semaine prochaine sauf
complication bien sûr elle y est
actuellement soigné pour une double
pneumonie vous le savez c'est ce qu'a
précisé un communiqué de l'assistance
publique christine prendra ensuite bien
sûr quelques jours de convalescence
avant de revenir diriger et présenter ce
journal j'ajoute une précision pour tous
ceux qui ont vu christine dans
l'émission de michel drucker le 31
décembre bien sachez que la séquence
avec christine avait été enregistré une
dizaine de jours auparavant
avant sa maladie en tout cas nous lui
souhaitons tous un rétablissement très
rapide voit la fin de cette édition du
journal tout de suite vous allez avoir
la météo avec laurent cabrol qui vous
donnera ses prévisions
ensuite dans la soirée 22h15 henri
sannier pour un flash d'information
édition spéciale juste après puis 23h40
le dernier journal télé matin ce sera à
6h45 demain matin avec roger zabel
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
soir